[Music]
chairman and easy online senior music
editors Sophie's you lacy have more
queen bee love they join us from our
absolute lime and green room at the look
back at 60 years of Grammys greatest
moments
[Music]
my artist of my life is Beyonce that of
course is Adele's acceptance speech at
last year's Grammys I adore you and I
want you to be my mommy all right this
Sunday's Grammys show celebrates 60
years of amazing moments just like that
word of course et has been at so many of
them and we are counting down her
favorite that is Queen Bee herself
rocking out with her idol the legendary
Tina Turner I was fighting back tears
literally the dream of my life just
happened unexpected moments are what the
Grammys are all about Elton John and
Eminem's friendship started after this
incredible moment on stage in 2001
now Eminem had been accused of being
homophobic so performing with Elton he
was making quite a powerful statement
there so many incredible moments now
this year absolute line with no added
sugar and no artificial flavors is back
as the official spirit sponsor of the
60th annual Grammy Awards pink Lady Gaga
Bruno Mars Rihanna just some of the
names scheduled to perform but the
Grammys will be booking acts right up
until Sunday night so literally anything
can happen on that stage and the great
thing is the eclectic mix of performers
you get at the Grammys in collaboration
yes it's beautiful always the best
you